here's a story
officials dna found at slain las vegas
reporters crime scene what is this about
well there was a democrat who lost his
re-election
his name was robert telus he was
arrested late wednesday for murdering a
journalist
because a journalist had been writing
stories about him that were negative and
it cost him the election now the funny
thing is you know the immediate
assumption a lot of people have is that
he did it you know and i'm like he's
innocent until proven guilty man come on
we don't know that this guy did it and
don't expect me to trust the journalist
in this story so it's like you got a
democrat is he the bad guy you got a
journalist who's the bad guy what
happened and i'm like i don't know
because i don't know what happened
like i sure i think
from from reading this it really does
sound like in my opinion journalists
probably lying about this guy
he was he so there's there's multiple
people in this race but he's writing
about this one guy over and over again
like obsessed with him numerous stories
that's such an experience with that
strikes me as weird well yeah personal
bias i'm like what's the obsession
there's multiple people in this race
so why is this one guy you don't like
but i don't know for sure what i can say
is
for all we know this democrat had
nothing to do with it and he's just a
lead suspect for all we know he was
there but then he left and so they're
like you're at the scene of the crime so
you're under arrest for all we know the
journalists
was trying to stab him with a pen or
something i don't know yeah and he
defended himself i think we all agree
murder is not good we're not we're
against it um and of course innocent
until proven guilty i think that's why
it starts to be like we need more
evidence if his dna is found at the
crime scene how do we know it's his like
what is the context here uh the weird
detail about this story to me was that
he like arrived at his home in a hazmat
suit yeah which i was sort of like but
that's a bold fashion and they saw him
doing it right they were like waiting
for him or something uh there's a video
of him in the suit and they're like did
you kill him journalists were waiting at
his home so like i don't know who took
them off or what the context there was
but yeah that's weird but it's kind of
like what you were saying earlier before
we started recording we keep hearing or
we've heard for the past few years that
an instance like this is going to happen
on the republican side it's going to be
a republican that goes after a
journalist and kills them because of all
trump's you know anti-press
rhetoric and well i don't know if this
guy really did it but if he did do it
then that's not the case here it wasn't
the anti-press rhetoric from republicans
that caused this guy to possibly kill
the journalist right and if this
journalist you know if everything he's
writing was full of emotion and it's not
you know it's very biased and maybe not
factual like that's terrible reporting
and that is serious but you don't get to
vigilante kill him that's not how this
works either right right
i just it's it is interesting that so
many people immediately jump to ah the
democrat and then i'm like well let's
see how this one plays out but there is
a very interesting point in that
donald trump kept calling the press the
enemy of the people the fake news was
the enemy of the people and then we saw
people like brian stelter i loved this
because he wrote an article three years
ago where he said trump falsely accuses
news organizations of fabricating
sources
and then a couple years later get us it
today caught fabricating sources so it's
like yellow and apology but they kept
saying that trump's rhetoric was
dangerous it was going to get
journalists killed
and now it's actually a democrat being
accused of doing it so it's like is
there going to be an apology across the
board for the trump supporters who are
restraining themselves because
apparently
trump trump said um
that the the real opponent was the media
that they were running against because
you know it's not the democrats it's the
media so any any apologies or no yeah
they're going to keep pushing the
narrative that maga republicans are the
evil ones are the the dangerous ones are
the threat when you have i mean this is
in line perfectly with antifa going
around smashing up windows destroying
businesses killing people
and then they ignore it and saying yeah
but the trump support is the problem
yeah i've barely even heard about this
story honestly besides us talking about
it and seeing some conservative
commentators talk about it on twitter
um and so obviously if this were a
republican we'd be hearing about it
constantly we'd be seeing tears and
quivering chins on cnn like oh my
goodness it's so difficult for me to
come to work every day we already saw
aoc say in gq that she doesn't even know
if she's going to be alive in september
and so
there would be journalists saying the
same thing and they would say this is
the cost of republican extremism but now
it's barely a peep well we talked about
the other day aoc saying she didn't know
if she's going to be alive what do you
think she meant by that
i think that she thinks that the same
people who
apparently put a dagger to the throat of
democracy on january 6th they're going
to come kill her in her apartment before
she can you know zip away in her touch
we we talked yes if a waiter tesla those
things go fast uh we talked about it too
but i think there's a possibility that
she's depressed
oh i think so i think she deals with
really serious insecurity probably but
also this like insufferable arrogance
which i don't think is the exact
opposite of deep insecurity i think they
often go hand in hand and to me she
seems like um
she's unsure of herself while also
trying to kind of present herself as
totally sure if that makes sense yeah i
posited that she is maybe going through
a transition in her beliefs and she
can't transition
yes that's what i'd like to suggest i
mean she just got engaged this year
perhaps she's talking about having a
family and now she is uh
maybe having to face some of the
consequences of the policies that she's
pushed maybe she doesn't feel that way
and she's become the figurehead for
i don't want to bore everyone who's
listening especially specifically tim
and you know we heard me make this pitch
last night but like she was the poster
child for this liberal green new deal
pro feminist
squad that would be amazing if she
changed i think that she can't leave
politics and she can't reverse her
opinion well which is i
i don't like that for politicians so i
think that she was whether it's in her
head or real it seems like she was
really shaken up after january 6 like
she's talked multiple times in
interviews about how she's gone to
therapy how she's like she was scared
that she was gonna get raped scared that
she was gonna get murdered and like she
talks a lot more now it seems like than
she used to about like
men and how she feels objectified i do
wonder like that whole big booty latina
thing that happened with alex stein like
her fiance literally did nothing just
like stood there with their little dog
like i do wonder how much of like a
stable force he is in her life and if he
actually makes matters it's kind of
worse for her to have like a weak man by
your side i don't know we should do it
we should do a skit about
dr aoc and mr republican aoc or whatever
where she like drinks a formula and then
starts turning into a republican like
her dress turns from blue to red and
she's like
then she's like wearing a trump hat
that'd be awesome
[Laughter]
i hope the the alex stein the big booty
thing where he approached her on the
steps i'm kind of sad about the way it
has has been playing out because i feel
like it's for alex uh cortez that she
could
totally just laugh with him and laugh
about it and like what dude come on he's
like a comedian well that's how you get
he might even run for politics someday
like it could work out you know he's not
like he's a really smart guy and he has
a lot of compassion and it was very
unfocused for a while and he's starting
to hone it in and i would love to see
them smooth that over and well that's
serious see
she didn't know how to handle a troll
right alex stein knew what he was doing
he and he he has this really great bit
i watched a video of him recently where
there's people protesting him and he's
laughing saying i love you you're
amazing this is so awesome i'm so
honored that people protesting just for
me we made it guys this is so big that's
how you handle it because they're trying
to rile you up if aoc started laughing
and she like winked at him and then
waved it would have all blown over
mm-hmm it would have not have been
effective did in the video which is why
it was so funny she kind of was like oh
haha funny and then she
made the video like exactly adding all
the adjectives to her but that like he
did not say
juicy added like juicy luscious like he
didn't even say that maybe that's why
she did it she's like he's not he's not
actually reporting no no no she's it's
it's it's like it's like a an insecurity
thing where it's like he was he said my
booty was luscious
and juicy and i'm mad about it yeah and
i'm really mad i work out and i'm mad
that he noticed
i think that aoc is this interesting
study in
someone who doesn't have a clear path
forward like i think
she has a lot of ways she can fall from
this cove position and i think she's not
good at dealing with trolls or negative
feedback because she has been celebrated
for so long as this like iconic young
democrat latina and like
if those are things that you're proud of
cool celebrate them but i think when you
come from
the opposite end of the political
spectrum when you're more conservative
like you
often are in a position where you think
that you are going i mean i'm sure this
has been true for you and your careers
like you're in spaces where you are
often the enemy right you're often the
wrong opinion and you get used to sort
of having to let things roll off your
shoulders if you are in a circle we're
competing for praise you know you have
very few people who are probably saying
like i i don't like what you're saying
she probably a lot of people were like i
like her saying but i'd like it even
more if you said this i i i gotta say
i could not imagine this the stress she
probably deals with it's probably
unbearable i can't imagine because we
know
how awful it is
on the left when you're dealing with
cancer culture so so i have a friend
who is uh you know as a lefty guy and he
was saying that someone he knows and has
worked with is getting canceled right
now for wrongfink or something and then
he's like do you think i should
criticize him call him out too or should
i just try and keep my head down and say
nothing and i said
i think
it's insane that you choose to live that
way yeah but a man so this is a guy
who's he's on the outside he just
happens to like he's in the in he's in
an industry that's woke and he's like
this is how it is so do i join the mob
or do i hide from them imagine being at
the epicenter of the mob like aoc and
everyone's constantly glaring at you
with darted you know evil eyes waiting
for you to say the wrong thing
she probably doesn't know what to say
half the time she's probably like
sitting there sweating bullets terrified
that at any moment it could all be
ripped away from her by cancel culture
you think so i i have a hard time
believing the laughs would turn on her i
mean unless she went like full maga what
i think i mean what is a lot of really
stupid stuff and the left has never been
like hmm maybe we shouldn't be putting
her on the cover of that she got
attacked she got attacked when she
walked back her stance on israel and
palestine when she initially did when
she initially got elected she got asked
about it and they were like you said
something that you know israel was an
apartheid i can't remember exactly what
it was yeah and then she was like well i
should probably look into that a little
bit more and they started relentlessly
attacking her saying like how could you
do this you're you're going corporate
being on the left is like you're
constantly in a precarious position like
you're constantly walking on eggshells
always like so imagine being surrounded
by zombies yeah and you're pretending to
be a zombie and if you slip up they're
coming for you yeah but imagine being
on the pedestal with every zombie
looking at you
you can't screw up and she has to have
an answer for everything that has to be
the right answer i mean that is a
tremendous amount of pressure well
especially when she can't she's really
not and i'm not just trying to be like
like troll her like she really isn't a
very good talker like she really doesn't
talk very well she has a hard time
talking and so i can't imagine
maybe maybe that's why maybe it's
because she has to overthink every
single word that comes out of her mouth
i don't know i don't know i mean i what
i said the other day was you know what
if you know she's getting married what
if she wants to not run for re-election
she wants to start her family and she
wants to be in new york more for her but
can you do that when you are the
champion of you know feminism and like
you know women at work like she could be
an influencer she'd probably make a lot
of money i mean i think i wouldn't i
personally wouldn't care i wouldn't
think less of how what she you know i
think she would be as committed to
whatever ideology but i could see other
people who feel like she is the example
of the young
successful professional who was a
bartender and she hustled she got to
congress and you know whatever she's
doing and if she says like my family
life is more important to me than
politics and this career like there are
people who i think would really drag her
for that and i can't imagine having to
you know
weigh my personal choices as it reflects
on a larger ideological movement it's
not just drag her i just wonder who's
behind her like the people who first
chose her and put her up and are pushing
her to be this like representation of
like the future revolution i feel like
she probably has a lot of pressure
behind the scenes that we don't i just i
think she must get it from all
directions and even though i don't agree
with her the majority of the time i
would argue to say almost all of the
time i still have a lot of you know i
just i would hate to be in her position
in some some respects it must be
uh unbearable at times yeah i think
about i don't want to turn people off
from running for office because we need
people good people in office but how
horrifying it would be to serve on the
bridge of the death star like they're
they're creating where do we go to war
next where do we send the military
machine on earth who do we kill who do
we defend who do we kill so that we can
defend what where do we get our lithium
where do we get our oil where do we get
and it's not all congress but
i mean that that stress on top like real
i think that's part of this red pilling
you said that you feel like she's having
some sort of mental resurgence or like i
just wonder i speculate like once you
realize that you're like the bad guy and
that we're like our government has been
the bad guy for like 70 years and
there's a lot of bad guys we're all
pretty much a bunch of brutes beating
each other in the playground as like
what governments are on earth up to this
point but it's not like you're not going
in to smile wave and then you know sign
some legislation so that everyone gets
their food there's not enough food we
don't have enough food for everybody or
if we do it's not organized properly
that's why people are starving in places
i kind of feel like though that she's a
narcissistic sociopath
so i don't know if she actually has
those those feelings and i know that
might be like
i'm not trying to be hyperbolic or you
know like overtly demonize like i
genuinely think the things she's done
signify that she's a narcissistic
sociopath
like she lied about what happened on
january 6 she totally fabricated this
insane story that made no sense
the timeline didn't make sense you know
the story where should the guy knocked
her door and said where is she yeah that
she she said oh i think they they like
she she implied the writers got to her
and she was scared of that but at that
point in her story based on her own
timeline the capital had not even been
breached it wasn't breached until an
hour later yeah so she just literally
fabricates this whole story yeah for for
and then what kind of person is willing
to do something like that
because the thing is
she she's she's been caught she's been
caught she's exposed for doing it and
she still doesn't care
because
she's got her cult little cult cultists
who follow her and just believe what she
says yeah i don't know if i would call
it narcissism i think about humility and
pride and it's not being humble isn't
self-hatred being proud isn't self-love
necessarily um what is narcissism like
excessive self-love to a fault yeah that
you orient everything around you which i
i would agree with the narcissism piece
i don't know if i would say that she's a
sociopath unfortunately i just think
that people
are bad people without having some kind
of like psychological diagnosis i think
that she just thinks about herself it
seems like constantly which is part of
why i think she's really sad like and
and part of the reason why she can't
take any criticism really because every
time someone criticizes her for a
totally valid reason she turns it into
this is an attack on my identity
no one's ever criticized her they're
only trying to date her exactly yeah i
was gonna say remember when she went to
florida with her boyfriend and people
like wait this is like against lockdown
protocol and she was like stop trying to
date me it's crazy i mean that's
something that a narcissist would say
most people even if you didn't think it
was fair that's not where your mind
would go thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you